Let's find the domain and range of another rational function. This time I want
us to look at y equals x times x squared minus 1 over 2x squared times x
squared minus 3x plus 2. To figure out the domain You'll need to look for
values of x where the function is undefined, focusing of course on the
denominator. To figure out the range, first see if this function has a
horizontal asymptote, and if it does, see if any values of x that we can plug
in, End up giving us that value Y that we saw in the asymptote. For this quiz I
would like you to tell me the domain and the range, by simply writing in the
values that X and Y cannot equal. If more than one value belongs in a single
box, separate your answers by commas. If you want to leave up box blank, then
write the word none instead.